en el centro de Grecia se impacientan
dentro de unos minutos Alexis cifras ex
Primer Ministro y líder de la izquierda
radical saldrá su encuentro y les
prometerá soluciones a la inflación
galopante que está paralizando los
hogares promesas en las que algunos
quieren creer sobre todo cuando al final
de mes se presenta difícil para el
bolsillo leonono recibo mi salario del
primero de cada mes pero del 17 al 18
del mismo mes Busco las monedas para
comprar el pan la leche o los productos
básicos mi factura de la luz pasó de 140
a 650 a 700 euros de una sola vez eso lo
dice todo en las encuestas el líder de
la oposición está por detrás del actual
Primer Ministro conservador kiriacos
mitsutakis pero el sistema proporcional
simple puede notar al ganador la mayoría
absoluta por esta razón Alexis cifras
quiere creer en una oportunidad para
volver al poder
ha llegado el momento de un cambio real
la sociedad griega lo necesita y el
pueblo lo quiere creo que daremos Una
gran sorpresa en las elecciones y que mi
partido ganará con mucha diferencia
pero para formar una mayoría en el
parlamento cipras tendrá que unirse con
otros partidos de izquierda incluida la
tolda política de Janis barufakis el ex
ministro de finanzas de cifras que ha
estado mostrando un fuerte impulso en
las encuestas últimamente y que está
haciendo campaña por un retorno a la
soberanía financiera para Grecia
tomaré mi revancha cuando este país
vuelva a ser viable económicamente
cuando el pueblo salga de la prisión de
la deuda en la que el país quedó
Atrapado en 2015 al aceptar la
austeridad a pesar del rechazo expresado
en referéndum y que me llevó a retirarme
del gobierno
ahora Alexis rechaza una salida de la
eurozona al igual que cualquier
coalición con Janis de quedar sin
gobierno el país se vería probablemente
obligado a convocar nuevas elecciones a
principios de julio